ciao bentornata stories ottimo vidi in
cui dobbiamo in do min ha raccolto e
questa volta fighissimo dobbiamo
indovinare cosa sono le cose zoomate che
in macro c'è una serie di corde super
sommate noi dobbiamo indovinare cosa
solo da questa particolare parte zoomata
che vedere insomma se riusciamo a
indovinare
non ho ancora visto il video mappe il
tuo canale fa video figli siri si chiama
macro room sacco di video in macro però
nel mentre pensate che sia facile ma
credetemi non è falsi nel come sembra
perché molte cose zoomate non sono
commerciale immagineremmo abidjan
questa e mail quando l'ho vista pensavo
fosse tipo un sigaro una sigaretta un po
bruciata adesso vedendola un po più da
vicino verità qualcosa di diverso ma non
riesco comunque a capire che cosa possa
essere un matto quindi ovviamente come
sempre giocheremo insieme
segnatevi quante ne avete indovinate
corrisponderà a quanti punti avete fatto
e anch'io signora il mio punti alla fine
del video vi dirò quanto conti fatto
anche voi potete scrivermi commenti
quanti punti avete fatto potete scrivere
le vostre risposte di commenti così e
dopo vedo cosa pensavate che fosse e mi
metto a ridere
alla fine vediamo se avete vinto voi ha
subito io siete fargli infatti nei
corner
iniziamo subito oggetto
il numero uno è quello che vedete già
quanti auto avete avute già un po più di
tempo per pensarci
che cos'è secondo voi io come vi ho
detto prima pensavo appunto da lontano
fosse una sigaretta o strigaro tipo
pronunciato
però vedo che ci sono dei bei sopra non
lo so è stranissimo
io dico che è forse la parte di sotto di
un fungo anche se ha un bel po di perico
vedete vabbè siccome ho un fungo o un
frutto dico un fungo molto zoomato
scrivete voi nei commenti il numero 1
cosa pensate che sia
vediamo
[Musica]
no era zoom altissimo ancora di quanto
pensassi comunque era il cosiddetto il
rullino termine scientifico berlino
della mela si riusciti a indovinare o no
io no quindi zero punti vediamo il
prossimo che figata
ok prossimo
wow stop
allora secondo me questo è un per deron
e di stato vicinissimo che se non so
forse un po rovinato qua però io dico
che il numero due è un peperone super
firmato in macro finite voi il numero 2
che cosa è il secondo voi
vediamo
[Musica]
no non essendo aver pensato un peperone
perché in effetti queste mitiche aveva
facevano più pensare non poteva essere
un peperone insomma con quei segnati e
nel tempo della coca cola o finisci più
fate vista per voi per il numero che
cosa pensavate che forte e se avete
indovinato avete fatto un punto io
ancora zero prossimo
allora questi mi sembrano non so perchè
ma mi viene da pensare degli spaghetti
numero 3 che cos'è secondo voi scrivete
nei commenti a meno degli spaghetti o
del tipo però in realtà c'è un altro
colore è tenuto un idea forse so cosa
potrebbe essere o che qualche sorpresa
potrebbe essere il numero 3 scrivetelo
nei commenti
secondo me potrebbe essere una spazzola
per pulire tipo per quello che è
colorata una spazzola per pulire la
cucina il bagno
forse vediamo
[Musica]
no penso vicinissimo in cina erano un
esteso le dello spot tolino incredibile
finissimo vedere le cose così in macro
se avete indovinato di tifosi un punto
in bianco da zero cosa pensavate che
fosse prossimo numero 4
allora qua forse in fondo mi sembra di
pane forse con la carta una focaccina
non lo so perché ma la consistenza qua
mi sembra tipo pasta sfoglia non lo fa
un dolce
io dico va bene con pezzo di pane che
sta dentro la buccia magari scrivete voi
numero 4 nei commenti che cos'è secondo
voi scrivete scrivete vediamo
[Musica]
come ha fatto non animarsi ma l'edizione
numero 5 ok da libertà penso questa
perla perché si capisce più che altro
per questi contorni qua se fosse stato
intubato solo qua non l'avrei capito
sembra tipo una caramella gommosa sono
qua o non lo so qualcosa con lo zucchero
comunque numero cinque ragazzi scusate
ma io perdo sempre in conto numero 5
secondo me è una matita la parte sopra
della matica zoomata scrivete voi nei
commenti che cos'è secondo voi
[Musica]
la città è viva
ho fatto un punto finalmente come se
avete indovinato avete fatto un punto
numero 6
beh questo è un chiodo e una lametta con
un chiodo veramente possono me ricchio
taglierino
ok numero 6 il ri con taglierino
scrivete voi nei commenti che cosa che
secondo voi
vediamo se capisci mente dopo è un
temperamatite mano come fatto un cappero
dal chiodino se avete indovinato avete
fatto un punto prossimo numero 6 that
but in festa roba
no non ho proprio idea di casa vostra e
rettore questa cosa qualche qualche
attrezzo forse ma non me ne intendo
quindi boh non lo so proprio
scrivete voi nei commenti numero 7 che
cos'è il secondo voi io mi arrendo per
questa spediamo
[Musica]
non era un accendino con dopo che strano
trento numero 8 ok si concentriamoci che
cos'è questo che strano mi fa pensare a
qualcosa di intrecciato una busta no non
può essere una busta da quelle buste
intrecciate non è difficile capire se
quella per punire i piatti un po più
quella un po più ruvida anche se va bene
numero 8 scrivete nei commenti cosa f
come voi secondo me mi butto dico una
spugna per pulire
non ci credo
e infatti questi spunti equa anno i
filetti un po più grossi si mima smette
di un punti finalmente l'indovino una
fatemi sapere poi cosa pensavate che
fosse numero 9 ma secondo me è un
accendino nuovamente questo perché
somiglia molto a quello di prima
forse la più grande io dico nuovamente
accendino
anche se si è già stato quindi mi sembra
strano che ci sarà di nuovo ma io dico
al sellino il numero 9 scrivete voi che
come chi numero 9 che cos'è se con voi
vediamo
[Musica]
a questo prezzo di cui nude al quale sia
il nome cioè praticamente il primo che
fa qui siamo tra il fiume lo cellino
questo presenterò questo nazioni numero
un attrezzo
vabbè numero 10
allora se ci sono dei figli e dei lacci
tipo di conto forse una scarpa ma questo
tessuto non può essere solo di una
scarpa dico una maglia a maglia di
tessuto un po particolare va beh l'icona
una maglietta una maglia con i fili per
chi le ha tratte da portarla no non mi
convince la mia risposta ma vabbè non
eri cosa stia numero 10 scrivete voi nei
commenti che cosa che secondo cui
vediamo
[Musica]
sì credo non si possa credere
questo mi ha lasciato veramente
scioccata e la politica di dio è
fighissimo vederli tutti ravvicinati
così zoom alti o film che nei commenti
se siete riuscite minarlo perché questa
veramente difficile sono ancora ferma
due punti
wow numero 11 ok questo è abbastanza
facile forse perché né un po di queste
le conosco abbastanza bene ma penso che
tutti voi indovinerete dai un numero 11
scrivete nei commenti per te è facile
dai e io dico che è una lente o c'è una
cameretta era con la lente oppure è solo
una lente di una camera
[Musica]
non mi aspettavo però che fosse un altro
pro mi aspettavo fosse una camera molto
più grande con una lente molto più
grande comunque lago prole comunque una
camera e questa è una letta e quindi
anche voi ne avete il sito lente o
camera insomma una videocamera
fotocamera avete fatto un punto
finalmente salvo tre punti prossimo
numero 12 mi sembra vediamo un po
forse lo so cos'è questo ok forse ho
capito perché mi è capitato quali a
volte di vederle da vicino numero 12
iscrivetevi i commenti che col 3 con cui
secondo me è una lampadina perché se
riguardate le lampadine dentro proprio
così dentro quindi penso che sia una
lampadina
vediamo
sì quattro porti finalmente fatto punto
in più ma occhio che schifo numero 14
qualcosa di schifoso però su questo mese
tipo forse non lo so mi viene in mente
forse anche questa è una sorta di spugna
per pulire che si è sporcata molto
sembra cicogna o qualcosa per pulire una
spazzola forse che si è sporcata molto
fine poiché come il numero 14 che cos'è
il secondo voi
vediamo
[Musica]
mancano 8 come ho fatto a tentarci oggi
ovunque è troppo figo vedere queste
macro così ravvicinate siete riuscite a
indovinarlo questo numero 14 si o no io
non ho più quattro punti numero pensi
allora questa è una cosa che mi sembra
di aver già visto che conta mi sembra di
è qualcosa che mi sembra che vedo spesso
ma non mi viene in mente niente nostro
numero 15
non lo so e familiare ma non ho niente
in mente proprio niente quindi scrivete
voi nei commenti numero 15 che cos'è
secondo lui mi accendo per questo amo
[Musica]
perché è uno migliore perché la vedo
ogni giorno tra l'altro poco più una
chiave con i lucchetti così con i
sacchetti così che deve sempre guardarla
per riconoscere se cura del portone
della dedicata dove credere che non lo
indovinato voi l'avete indovinata siamo
in quarta e alla fine purtroppo
numero 16 oddio questo sembra qualcosa
schifosissimo ci fu un pelo un cappello
ma si capisse mi sembra della terra
terra anche se non so perché si essere
sopra che sotto non lo so forse e tipo
la suola di una scarpa che accanto è
stato del fango ha vinto più fantasiosa
numero 16 scrivete voi nei commenti
che cos'è secondo voi vediamo
[Musica]
non ci credo è uno schifosissimo
maggiore lo sono buonissimi non ci posso
credere
wow siete riusciti a di dominarlo
prossimo
[Musica]
ok numero 17 mi sembra questo è facile
questo lo bello perché si capisce
abbastanza bene scrivete voi nei
commenti
17 che cos'è secondo voi secondo me è
una penna perché si vede bene qua la
punta della penna e questa parte di
plastica fa insomma vediamo
sì il rumore sono cinque punti almeno
era una penna prossimo
ok allora questo penso che sia tipo una
tv con uno schermo perché da vicino si
vedono così sybelle così se lavorate
molto da vicino
quindi penso una tv vecchia uno schermo
tv numero 18 scrivete voi nei commenti
cosa taciuti che sia cioè personal tv
mara sarà lo schermo del telefono quindi
non so se darmi un punto no forse non
perché non lo ho detto tv quindi no
[Musica]
e purtroppo sta diventando troppo
bellissimo vedere cosa in macro a
memoria fa anche altri video da farvi
vedere in cui dobbiamo appunto
indovinare così macro maurice che la
camera sta già registrando da un po di
tempo e non voglio che questo video sia
appunto lunghissimo però se questo video
raggiunge i 10 mila vice farò un altro
episodio del pd dobbiamo indovinare le
cose in macro facesse sapere quanti
punti avete fatto io cinque in tutto mi
avete battuta o no se siete divertiti
volete altro video del genere fatelo
sapere nei commenti ora vi lascio qua 4
cartelline su cui potete cliccare
prevedere i prossimi video clicca su
quella che prevede e buona visione
dunque